need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe nation because i love it
there is no discipline without a
schedule
it's so easy if your calendar doesn't
have anything in it the next six weeks
don't be mad at yourself for lacking
discipline no one shows up on they go
it's discipline day
and has nothing to do
discipline requires the schedule so fill
out your schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule work the schedule
fill out the schedule works as you fill
out your schedule and you work the
schedule
you get more self-trust with that
self-trust comes confidence from that
confidence comes more competence we gain
more mastery and we're in the game more
we feel good about ourselves the
progress mind loves it eats it up it's
like hey we're doing it we said we were
gonna do it we did it we moved towards
our outcome today with a schedule what
an idea rule number two explore the
world's menu put yourself in new
novel situations
to discern what you like
i'm sure many of you guys you get the
questions too from you know younger kids
in their you know teens or in their 20s
who ask you you know but i don't know
what my passions are and what do you
always say
go do stuff
you like
passions
and interests
emerge
[Music]
out
of actions
not contemplations
so you don't just sit around and
contemplate what am i passionate about
and come up with something you need to
experience the menu of the world a
little bit and go oh i like this
just like i never knew i liked sushi i
never sat in a room one day in montana
and go i like sushi no i had to go
experience culinary from all over the
place and i went to a sushi place i'm
like
i'm a guy that likes sushi
and now if you hang out with me i'm like
i'm passionate about sushi i never
thought in a room i'd be passionate
about sushi one day i had it
and became passionate about it you find
your passions by living an active life
when you don't have passions we just got
to get more menu in front of you this is
why you always
growing
your network and your relationships to
discern like a lot of people hope their
purpose just lands on them like your
purpose is found out in the world
your purpose is found by living
and choosing how you want to live and
living a purposeful life and more
purpose shows up if you want deep
relationships with people you're going
to have to uncover
your passions
you're gonna have to express
those passions
and you're gonna have to elicit
their passions rule number three embody
your message the third thing that great
leaders are always doing is embodying
their message they stand for something
there's a congruence between who they
are the behaviors that they're enacting
into the world how they treat people
what they're working towards and what
they say is important right that that's
it's just basic line it's integrity you
know it's a congruence to believe
between what we say we're after and how
we are behaving
and there's nothing more important is
there
you know it's like it's that old message
it's like you don't believe the message
unless you believe the messenger
so as leaders we have to stand for and
demonstrate and show and portray
what we are really believing in i mean
are we really are there is our team and
the people around us seeing us work for
it sweat for it sacrifice for it
champion it over and over and over again
even when it's hard even when there's
conflict even when people are pissed
even when people want to quit are you
still there
do you still stand for it if you do you
become a legend rule number four repair
within 48 hours you got
48 hours tops to repair
which i believe is super generous i used
to teach i used to teach you get four
hours to repair
and i was very well educated by some
marital therapists being like well
that's not everyone's style some people
don't go sit away
but if
you sit on it for more than 48 hours you
have to understand their memory
and your memory has now coalesced
against something being true
and the longer you wait to repair
the more what you believe to be true is
solidified and calcified
and it's harder to change a perspective
or to let go of that
right it's calcified it's hard now it's
harder it's more fluid
in real time
and in the moments and hours afterwards
to being defined
and released
the longer you hold it on because you
some of you know this some people
are holding on to stuff that happened to
them
20 years ago
i i remember going back to a high school
reunion i was talking to a friend
and i think it was our 25th and 20 25th
20th 20 was talking about something that
happened in high school
and
the way they were i could not believe
they were still
so upset about it now i
in my mind
thank god i thought okay well that was
traumatic for this person
um i have to understand that but if
there's still
bitterness hatred anger but also most
importantly
judgment against others
now we're trapped in the ego and we need
some help
because that's the difference maker like
we can have something that was traumatic
but if it's still in that place where
there's vitriol and judgment against
others that becomes very toxic in our
own mindset and we got to deal with that
stuff again sometimes that takes therapy
to learn to repair those things but in
motion with your relationships i'd love
to set that 48 hour rule for you i
personally am a believer i came up in
different culture i came up in the never
go to bed angry thing
go to bed like repair resolve
coordinate love
like let it go and go to bed i know
that's not true for everybody so maybe
you gotta eke it out in that next day
but i would say if by the end of 48
hours you haven't brought up that you're
upset
that is a weakness
in your communication style
not something to continue holding
against them
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five don't fear judgment how
often does your passion show up in a
group setting every week
how often does your passion
show up in a group setting every week
well if it's not
that explains why the bonds of the
groups that you're around aren't that
deep
yet you have to both inject your passion
into conversations so people actually
know what you
think about what you're interested in
what you're deeply thoughtful about like
all of your friends and i want you to
write this down all of my friends should
know my passions
all of them
otherwise they're strangers
all your friends
i'm a person like if you know me you're
gonna know my passions real fast i and
people say yeah but i can't tell my
family this they think that or i can't
tell her that they think that i'm like
what are we in high school
are you really holding back your
passions based on what someone else will
think
that's okay
in high school once you're at 18 that's
no longer allowed now that's just called
sabotaging yourself for no reason
whatsoever other than your internal
fears of embarrassment which by the way
shouldn't last that long after 18 years
old not when you're doing the personal
development work like get over that it's
okay everyone should know
and if they have judgment to it guess
what they also judged your clothes today
they also judged your hair today they
judge your website who cares why is
everyone so scared about judgment the
less you are worried about judgment the
greater friends you have
when you realize
if because you know what i want people
i want people to reject me
because if i'm not in their tribe or i'm
not their guy great i don't go spend a
bunch of time trying to build
relationship with somebody who's like
that
so don't fear the judgment
and don't keep pressing down suppressing
or quieting your passions to try to fit
in
to try to be liked
share what you love
share your passions rule number six
enlist other people as you're developing
this vision it's not just your vision
you're enlisting other people to share
their voices their perspective their
dreams their desires for where you could
be going you know i think that the most
important leadership lesson in the world
is that people support
what they create
if people are involved in the ideation
of a vision they're involved in creating
ideas of brainstorming of figuring out
what is it we are about what do we stand
for where are we going great leaders
enlist that from other people they're
constantly asking people what they think
how they feel what think what the things
they desire and need and it's that
enlistment that is always going on a
great leader is always enlisting other
people to
to believe in the dream to shape the
dream to stay dedicated to the dream
it's an honest and uh authentic and a
genuine desire to see other people be
involved in the process and to enjoy
that process i mean it's so vital and
that methodology of what you know how do
you get people involved in it you're
asking questions you're paying attention
to their needs you're reflecting back to
things that you're hearing you're always
enlisting others to support and to build
this vision this ideal future together
rule number seven practice explicit
communication we must be more explicit
when we're upset with people and let
them know i would say 9 out of 10 things
that i do to upset denise i have no clue
and i don't think is a big deal at all
but the one out of 10 she tells me i'm
like
oh i'm an idiot i'm sorry
you like explicit communication is the
most important thing in all of repair
all of it you must say it you must not
hint at it you must not be passive
aggressive you must use the words
to describe exactly how you felt
and what your request is for next time
describe how you felt not decide what
they did describe how you felt and then
make the repair request for next time
next time that happens can we do this
you must know
your outcome
how can you possibly be focused or
disciplined if you don't know the
outcome you're after
most people don't lack
focus or discipline
they lack clarity that would give them
the focus and the discipline
that's why the first high performance
habits is seek clarity we learned it
from our research right
well an outcome what am i after here
what's the goal what's the tangible
or intangible thing that i know when i
get there
when i see that feel that experience
that achieve that
that's what i'm after here that some
kind of outcome you won't stay
disciplined unless you can see feel
sense
acknowledge intellectually what the
outcome is we're after
if you're not disciplined on a
consistent basis it's because you don't
know what you want
so don't beat yourself up that you're
lazy you just need to make a decision
you need to make a decision about what
it is that you want and it doesn't have
to be what you want for your whole life
your ultimate grand purpose and the
cosmos of the destiny of the universe no
no what do you want by friday
what do you want by the end of the month
what do you want this quarter
it's it's like start there
if you're really confused about the next
five years of your life please start
with the next five weeks of your life
come on
you people don't understand clarity
is built upon
you don't have the epiphany where
everything is perfect very few people
ever have a complete perfect picture
epiphany moment of everything coming
together in life very few people very
few people
instead usually what happens is as we
move throughout our lives we get a
little more clarity what we like and
what we don't like what draws passion
and strength and contribution what
doesn't
know your outcome you want this one know
your outcomes rule number nine support
your friends does anyone have a friend
who talks on and on and on about
something that you aren't passionate
about at all
anyone out there
encourage them
keep listening
don't we all need friends like that
it's important
it's important
for you to elicit other people's
passions and it's okay if there isn't i
have one friend that is so passionate
i mean insane like
otherworldly passion about video games
now i haven't played a video game and
i don't know i don't know how to use the
controllers anyone else have that you
ever go to your friend's house and their
kids pop out the video game they hand it
to you and you get this controller and
it's like a spaceship and you don't even
know what it does
that's me i don't know i don't know how
to play a video game i'm not interested
in video games at all like it's not even
i'm not even interested in it and i have
this friend
we will go out and he will tell me about
video games for like 90 minutes
and i'm so
interested
because that's his passion
when someone's talking passion you know
what you say tell me more
it doesn't have to be your passion stop
listening for what you want to be and
experience and who you are
and honor and see the other
their passions their ideas their goals
their concerns
that's how to win friends and influence
people and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
make someone's day adopt a little bit of
a mischievous mindset here's what i
encourage you to every morning when i'm
in the shower i think what can i do
today this little mischievous and fun
for somebody not fun for me fun for
somebody what what can i do to to to to
cajole to tease to to prank somebody who
i love not in a me or disheartening way
and but in a real fun way what what can
i do to to make some fun between us to
make some jokes and stories between us
what unique things could i do to make
somebody say even if just think of this
what could i do today to make somebody's
day
and you know what you'll find that fun
and fulfilling and when you start having
days that are much more fun and
fulfilling and you have weeks that are
more surrounded by friendship doing
things that you care about that you find
fun and you're fully immersing yourself
in those experiences well over a period
of time all that fun and that
fulfillment that gives you
the charge left
empowerment means we give people the
decision-making authority and the trust
to be able to work towards this vision
to allow them the autonomy the strength
the input to equip them with the
knowledge the skills the abilities the
technologies the tools the training to
allow them to succeed as they march with
us to achieving something extraordinary
and phenomenal that's
vital that's what empowerment is about
and a lot of leaders who come in with
the big vision they get everyone excited
you know they they seem like they they
want everybody involved and they do a
great job of standing for it but they
don't equip their teams to kick some
butt
they never get to that place of real
stride of real momentum and that happens
all the time
training other people and equipping them
with everything they need to succeed has
to be a vital practice of every great
leader and again it doesn't happen just
once that's a huge failure in the
working world especially in corporate
america great leaders come in they nail
the vision they get people around it
they stand for something
but they only empower people at the
beginning they give some training and
then they just disappear
training has to be consistent coaching
has to be consistent equipping people to
deal with the new challenges the new
tools new technologies the new
competitive realities that's vital we
have to have that in place research
study in psychology found out that both
second person and third person makes you
more
makes yourself talk more powerful so if
you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say i wanna do this i
wanna do this you wanna do what we call
in the book self-coaching
where you would say you know in my case
yeah
brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it is i'm brendan yes yes another one
another one i do every morning yeah
assuming i take a shower but every
morning the shower because we all don't
every day not every morning no we do not
this doesn't happen it does not happen i
told you like 24 hours ago i was staying
in a barn in the woods at a friend's
house yes um
but the second thing i ask myself in the
in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate you know something's gonna go
wrong during the day absolutely and if i
already know everything like like this
morning's was okay
you're in
i think what we would i think i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying what
do you call it north you're uptown i'm
uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown okay so i'm like
okay that's gonna be 45 minutes it's a
hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get impatient yes and i
get stressed and i don't want to feel
that so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with marie brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here i know that sounds
completely crazy but every high
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it i mean at high level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers outside of teaching people to
bring the joy in my life
i teach people to honor the struggle
honor the difficulty
when we honor the struggle instead of
hate the struggle
we can really achieve extraordinary
things because our mindset's in the
right place it accept like as soon as
you honor the struggle you accept that
oh of course there should be struggle
here i should i should honor this
process when you go to the gym to work
out you like honor that this is going to
be hard and it honored that process of
getting better and the more that you
bring honor to it the more your psyche
builds with strength and you get a
little bit of that esteem back
because you see yourself engaging
something versus avoiding it and running
away
you see yourself connecting with
something and giving it
reverence
you're like like i have reverence for
the difficulties of life they may be
better
so i don't want a friction free life i'm
not interested in it you know the the
the
i like to say sometimes that you know
the journey to greatness begins
the moment that
our you know deep desires for comfort
and ease
are overpowered
by our desires to connect and contribute
what is that habit that you take on on a
daily or monthly basis with howard with
clarity what do you think about you're
like every morning what am i clear about
or yeah you know how do you apply that
habit to your life i apply in a couple
ways
first for me
every situation i go into
i'm consistently asking like what what's
the feeling i want to
have here if you ever see me teach it's
often i would say bring the joy
so i have joy triggers that i've set up
in my mind that makes me more
intentional about things so for example
a door frame trigger whenever i walk
through a door i say bring the joy
so when i walk through that door right
there it's like bring the joy into this
room
it's just it's just a mental trigger
that i've set up for myself every
morning in the shower i ask myself three
questions
and not that i shower every morning but
the ones i do
the first question i say what can i be
excited about today
so it forces me to be clear about what's
going to draw joy enthusiasm for me
number two i say
what might trip me up today
because usually i know what's going on
today i'm like what what might mess me
up what my where might i perform well
what might bother me and number three i
say what can i do to surprise somebody
today to give a gift of appreciation or
acknowledgement today and so i think
through that in the morning so i think
that helps me begin my day pretty clear
then when i sit down before i do work
i literally look at my calendar of the
day this morning
and i look at whatever's going on the
day and i think about it for 20 minutes
it's one of my 20 minute routines in the
morning i literally
think about my calendar
for 20 minutes a day
people think that's crazy
but what i'm thinking through when i'm
looking to count i'm like okay i'm going
to have that call
what do i want to happen on that call
you know what's my intention for that
call what's my goal for that call what's
the feeling for that call how do i want
to end that call
you know i'm going to have that time
with louis like how do i want to be
there and and and how can i make sure i
enjoy it because it's a big deal you
know i love your show i want to do a
good job i want to share something good
for the people you know i have no idea
what you're going to ask right
i want to be present for that and and
make sure i i'm i'm really there even
though maybe i have a head cold today
you know it's like that it's like just
thinking through it i think
that helps me
it keeps me asking questions every
sunday i do a life arenas assessment
that just means i think there's 10 areas
of our life
and i score myself in them
and this is about my 11th year of doing
this wow so each area of my life you
know from
from emotional quality to happiness to
relationships to time to hobby et cetera
i just give myself a score of one to ten
and one means i suck
and i i was horrible in the previous
week on that ten means i did a good job
and then i asked how can i do better
it's my sunday routine yeah and it just
keeps me clear
and it's not like i don't
sometimes like everyone else you know
wonder what's going on or what i'm doing
but
those habits those were my habits you
have to establish your own for seeking
clarity but when you have them
you weaponize your life transitions
takes place in
the chapter of generate energy and also
maybe it's in productivity too uh and it
has this converse it's just a
conversation
that
if you're go go go go all the time
you're depleting energy all day and you
don't know it and lots of people think
to get more energy or more productive
they have to radically change their life
i'd better work out an extra 60 minutes
in the morning it's like actually let me
teach you the mastery of managing
transitions when you go from one
activity
to another i want to teach you this
simple thing and that is release tension
set intention
very simple let me give you an example
because it really helps if you're doing
email
and you know that that takes one part of
you your your psyche and brain to do a
lot of email and now you're gonna go
create that keynote or that powerpoint
presentation that you want to be flowing
and visual and beautiful very different
things what most people do is they'll do
their email and then they'll work a
little on the presentation then the
notification come over here and then go
back to the email and then they're
multitasking yes and they're wrecking
not only their measurable creativity but
their long-term performance and so what
you have to do is
when you finish the email stop it
okay maybe go get some water come back
or whatever even if you don't all i do
push away from your chair for a minute
close your eyes
repeat the word release
with
the goal of releasing tension in your
body
and repeat the word release yourself
several times over and over like a
mantra
okay just three p it could be 60 seconds
it could be one minute can be two
minutes whatever you want to do
just do it until you feel like your body
and your mind release a little bit
then
before you open your eyes set an
intention say okay
brenden you're gonna work on this
keynote now your intention is to make
something that grabs them right at the
beginning and then make it really move
fast and make it um
make it visual and make sure that it
builds emotionally throughout the thing
so when you make a call to action at the
end bam
and then open my eyes network on
presentation i'm clean and free from the
previous activity yes
and people will feel an unbelievable
amount of energetic just power come back
from there i interviewed or i've worked
with
a major founder in the startup silicon
valley world flew me down at 3 00 am and
i guess it was around after midnight on
private jet it was it's great he was
having a lot of trouble just exhausted
literally depleted um you know this
person's incredibly well valued in his
company lots of employees everyone knows
who the person would be
but miserable
just go go go go go and i said what's go
and one of his major things was he was
wrecking his relationship with his wife
and his children
because not because he was
maybe just overworking he would just
carry a lot of the work into his house
yep so when i say i said i want you to
pull up to your house
after the day of working don't get out
of the car
pull up the pull up the house
just close your eyes repeat the mantra
release to yourself maybe five minutes
and then before you open your eyes set
the intention how do you want to be with
your wife when you enter
the house
what kind of dad do you want to be to
your daughter
just set that intention
open up your eyes now go in as a
different man
and it changed his life his email to me
is in the bible
it's fantastic it just works that means
just release tension yep set intention
it's just your transitions are where
most people is bleeding out their energy
and they don't know and if we can just
get you four or five times of transition
really well throughout the day you
finish your day like i feel amazing yes
and we didn't we didn't caffeinate you
we didn't do anything we just changed
how you approach your work get up in the
morning i drink 20 ounces of water
i do 20 minutes of mobility movement and
stretching every morning
then i read for 20 minutes something
positive for me it's almost always a
self-help book or a leadership book
almost always sometimes a business book
almost always self-help and leadership
read that book then
i
go and i sit down
with my high performance planner my
green tea i fill out the day
right i look at the blocks of time that
are already scheduled
and then what i use is my second
visualization which is i look at the
major blocks of time that have been
scheduled just like this
this morning and i close my eyes
and i think
how do i do that thing with excellence
what would make that thing
special
so this morning before i got here
when i thought about this because
there's my high performance planner
impact theory tom bill you oh yes three
exclamation points literally so i looked
at the schedule it closed my eyes and i
thought okay
what do i want to communicate on tom's
show how do i want that to feel
what do i want to communicate so i
literally close my eyes and i visualize
those blocks of time
and how would i do them well
that's a superpower most people write
their day out and they just go about the
day and then they sometimes they come
back to the plan they go oh my god i
didn't even do it
because i sit there and i think about
how do i do that well
that's the game changer what does that
rebuilding process look like for
somebody who's trapped in depression and
suicidal thoughts yeah
um
i've been there a lot
in my life
especially
before my car accident my teenage years
than the first woman i ever loved we had
a
big breakup
and that breakup sent me down in
depression and suicidal planning
and uh
it's tough to dispense advice to people
other than get help and i'll share why
because that time in my life i had so
many people coming up to me
you know my friends would come into my
dorm room
let's go do something and you just
there's just the hope is lost
and what people i think make the mistake
of trying to do is hype people up
everything's gonna be okay you're gonna
be great
and what people need who are suicidal is
serious psychological intervention they
need to seek support and help and
outside of that
when they do get that support
the first thing a great therapist is
going to do
outside of the emotional reflection work
of why are you here and what has caused
this sort of pattern for you they're
going to get you starting to get some
momentum
the most important thing is when you are
super down
outside of finding that emotional
reasoning for where you are
is to start getting momentum because
with momentum comes hope with momentum
comes motivation with momentum comes
you know that feeling that there's a
reason for tomorrow
and so it's as simple as just saying
okay what are three things i'm gonna do
today
and
i don't mean that like a lot of personal
development guys would say like what are
your three big goals for the day ah i'm
like dude sometimes that first goal is
sh i'm gonna shower today
i'm really in shower today
uh
i'm gonna walk to the library
and come home
and that's all they got
like literally that's all they got
and you gotta honor that struggle
when you're in that place like know that
where you're at it is okay that you're
there and now you're gonna need help
and now you're gonna have to set up some
daily practices just every day win a
little bit
not like win your dreams not like crush
through goals not like be badass not
like no
just momentum man next habit is high
performers develop
influence
more than those around them
it's not because they're cool it's not i
mean look at me
i'm not getting ahead of my cool factor
here ladies and gentlemen i just got
these new nikes
what's your newest shoe they're like
these ones i'm like i need that and
they're like wow i'm like because lewis
has sneaks man i got
i i wear suits or like i'm either on
stage in a suit or or at my you know
studio kind of like you know kind of
formal too sure sure um i was like man i
gotta get some sneaks
i said give me your newest sneaker so
i'm not getting ahead on the cool i
don't develop influence because i'm cool
it's not your personality that gives you
influence it's how you treat other
people and specifically the way that
people high performers gain influence
is is this way too much
you know get it
how do you develop here's how you here's
how you develop influence
if you really want high level of
influence
obviously you got to do all the basics
treat people nice be kind and in the
book what i do is with each habit i say
here's the basics
but then i go here's what the needle
mover practices are
the highest performing influencers what
they're doing often they don't know
they're doing it by the way
the first thing they're doing is they're
teaching people how to think
a lot of your show
gained influence i really believe
because you're really good at teaching
people how to think
you're shaping their mindset
but high performers are really doing it
uh explicitly and you do this too where
you say
here's how to think about that guys or
high-performing leaders tell their team
here's how we should be thinking about
ourselves here's how we should be
thinking about the competition here's
how we think about the future of the
company they're saying it they're
explicit more often here's how to think
i mean the the the what is it the
seventh most read book in the history of
the world
is think and grow rich
crazy it became that way because he
taught people how to think about money
we have to tell our audience how to
think about things
the second thing they're doing
is they're challenging people
and they're challenging the specific way
if you listen to great orators great
speaker
the pros when i know i'm like oh this
person studied speech before
is they challenge the audience in three
ways they challenge the audience's
character
then they challenge the audience's
connections their relationships then
they challenge the audience's
contributions what they're giving
you hit all three of those the audience
is like i have to listen to her i have
to listen to him because not only are
they shaping how i should be thinking
because maybe i was thinking wrong
but now they're pushing me because you
know it's just like a great coach the
greatest coaches
they're not just saying throw the ball
better they're like louis you're a
better man than that come on man
they're saying look you're treating your
team like crap
they're look look you're not
contributing the team here that's a
different challenge than just throw the
ball faster or catch the you know
so i studied that from them but those
are the primary things and the third
thing of course is role modeling
you know standing i mean if i'm the
bring the joy guy or i'm the owner of
the struggle guy or i'm the high
performance guy and i'm off my game
people are gonna know that yeah
so that's i'm always trying to role
model what i do which is hard when
you're talking about high performance
because everyone thinks well don't you
have a bad day i'm like dude i
i have bad moments i would say bad days
because yeah i don't want to go to bed
and feel like the day was bad
but at the same time i think that's why
they're developing influence high
performers are not dissatisfied strivers
they're not they're happy high
performers are happier than their peers
we all believe that to get the top it's
gonna be lonely at the top and we all
believe you have to grind and kill
yourself to get there yeah and that's
completely wrong and the data proves it
worldwide
which is i think just overcoming a lot
of people's biases about how you work
today because right now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle or
hustle and by the way none of the top 15
of high performers worldwide
identify with those words
they literally don't we asked them we
did a whole keyword analysis yep this is
actually pretty cool and high performers
explicitly say these these are three
driving feelings if we said there was a
high performance state it's driven from
these three things number one full
engagement yes number two
joy yes
and number three confidence yes that's
what they relate with okay that's where
it's coming from it's a joyous journey
not a dissatisfied one and this i had
this conversation in the book um
because uh i kind of maybe
frame it this way each of these chapters
opens with a vignette
of somebody i worked with or a situation
that i was in that demonstrated high
performance in this particular situation
i'm walking on stage thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success remember
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was never settle
never settle nothing is enough never
settle and never be satisfied never be
satisfied always demand more and i'm
like oh
my second slide which is gonna be on
jumbotrons in like 80 point text
was strive satisfied
i'm like oh i'm gonna have to dispel
this for all these thousands of people i
was totally freaked out yeah
and but what i had to explain to people
was not only the data
but it's this uh
if you're never satisfied
i mean what
is it true that life is precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow do you really
want to think you know what i just never
felt fulfilled
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of peace i never allowed myself to look
at that and say good job
that's not the way to live life right i
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad move and this book doesn't really go
in a lot of that it's more about the
science and the heart stuff
but i think it's really important that
people realize
your job is to strive satisfied and if
you strive satisfied more often
you will be more of a high performer and
if you never give yourself credit you're
always beating up on yourself you're
always thinking that's not perfect
enough
then what's going to happen dissatisfied
people burn out and they quit
more often than satisfied strivers so
take joy in the moment
engage with what you're doing
allow credit and satisfaction enjoy to
come in you can always be improving of
course but be proving be improving
joyfully big development growth point
for people is determining
how do i really want to treat people
when they don't agree with me
or when they're hating on me
or when they're discounting me or
they're being mean to me or we're in a
fight
because i think some of those are the
greatest growth areas of our life at the
end of our lives
if we have a moment of cognition we're
going to lay there in bed
and
we're going to ask questions about our
life to evaluate whether or not we were
happy with it
and what i've always suggested to people
is
maybe don't pretend you're living your
purpose unless you know
the questions you're going to ask at the
end of your life how do you evaluate it
because otherwise you're just kind of
living randomly but when you know oh i'm
gonna evaluate my life this way at the
very end now every day you can wake up
with intention now every day you get to
wake up with purpose which is why i love
the name of your show because that's my
thing too
he's like
this this deep connection to some type
of purpose so that at the end of our
life we're happy there's no regrets
there there's no sadness there's no oh
my gosh why was i this way or why did i
wait to do that
and i my unique story
is that i got that gift at 19
years old people should want to have a
high level of joy and happiness in their
life yeah
but they cannot they cannot wait for it
i always say you know the power plant
doesn't have energy
it generates energy i mean technically
it transforms energy from one medium to
another and we can do the same thing
you know you don't have happiness you
have to generate the happiness you don't
have joy
you generate joy and when you learn to
take control of your power and your
energy in that way
then life becomes so much more
fulfilling and so much more fun and it
doesn't become fake or forced because
you know it's fake and forced
this all day yeah that's not your
natural state yeah i mean and here's how
you know take a person you know i just
got back from a big vacation with my
lady and and we were down on the beach
and through take any person
put them on a beach for a while and
they're not like
your natural state is like this is
beautiful this is great there's awe
there's inspiration there's joy there
tap back into that and you'll be more of
a high performer when you get the life
is really short and you felt that before
but either by you were threatened or
you've had someone
near and dear die but when you have that
real essence in you that says life is
short have reverence for it live it
that's a really big thing i got that at
19 and i learned specifically
that
if we have a moment of cognition before
the end of our life
we tend to ask questions to evaluate if
we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's
going to come from that experience where
i learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine
what the questions you're going to ask
at the end of your life are going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end
for me the answers the questions i had
were did i live
which i hadn't i hadn't been living my
life i've been thinking about taking my
life did i love
no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people
and i always say you know sometimes the
walls we put up to keep out the bad guys
prevent the good guys from getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is connection
and i learned that i would ask did i
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark caribbean night i'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
bleeding out
my friend
and i just wrecked a car he's screaming
at the top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car
looking down all this blood
and i'm in
terror
and i just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did i even matter
you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid i didn't know
about impact theory
for real i didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that i didn't know to think about
legacy
meaning
did i matter i didn't think i did but
the good news is i'm a good learner and
i felt like i got a second chance from
god that night and i learned
that it was really important for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again i'll know
i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to know know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally demonstrate courage
and i think all personal involvement
people of course you know
but they actually high performers do
demonstrate courage like we can measure
it from peer feedback we can measure it
from their self-assessments we can
measure it from we have this thing
called the high performance indicator
assessment you take it you get scored on
all six habits it's free on the internet
um on the interwebs um
but this one
peaked when we did the research and i
didn't know it and it is high performers
are more willing
to
share their ideas
their thoughts their feelings
what they need what they want
and they do it more consistently than
their peers even when there's risk or
uncertainty
um
you do a great job i know you have the
books coming out for you uh talking
about men and being vulnerable
that's demonstrating courage that's yeah
you know when you're not conditioned
that way or you're not used to that
you know that it might not seem like a
big deal but it it is yeah you know um
when you talked about me doing this
interview that was like it might not
seem like demonstrating courage to go on
lewis house but it is because i admire
you
and i also
i'm not used to sharing a lot you know
you usually let the work speak for
itself yeah so i had to like okay i need
to share
you know be willing to share this in
different and unique ways
but i think for most people it's
when you're in your last meeting
did you share for your ideas and fight
for them
do you share for yourself you share your
ideas and fight for them
when you wanted to post that video and
you were scared to death because people
are going to make fun of you did you do
it
and
when you wanted to tell your spouse that
you're not getting what you need
did you say it
because all those are demonstrating
courage it's not just you know
the courage we think you're pulling
someone out the river or something and
that's part of it and we talk about the
different kinds of courage in the book
human brain has this incredible capacity
for guilt
and most people unconsciously let that
roll over them and kick their butt and
make a horrible life i love guilt guilt
is a tool guilt is a weapon guilt does
not have to be a bad thing it's not like
i perpetuate but i'm like i love that i
feel bad when i don't do a good job
most people hate that about themselves i
love that feeling i'm like
i didn't do a good job there next time i
will
so some people
guilt is discouragement
other people it's a signal for learning
to me guilt is a signal for learning it
is the body and the brain the spirit
knowing what is right knowing what is
wrong knowing what's great knowing
what's mediocre and it's saying hey do a
little better now if it's translated
into a negative impulse then some people
call it guilt but i'm like i'm totally
cool with that i you know i think it's
good that we feel bad
when we do something that is below our
standard or
that's not right because that impulse to
go i want to do that better stage one
was i
was honest
that i was a hot mess
like i came back from the accident and
i'm like i'm a mess i've been depressed
i was gonna kill myself
i'm sad my grades suck my friends are
kind of like losers uh you know not in a
judgmental way to them but in how i
wanted to feel they made me feel bad
about myself
and that's why i think a loser isn't
what they've accomplished it's how they
make other people feel two different
things they made me feel bad and i
thought i
i don't have it together
and that began my
great and long-term committed search to
studying psychology because i'm like why
do i think so dumb
why do i feel so bad about myself
how do you overcome
you know depression how do i deal with
this sadness
why do i still have so much hatred in my
heart about something that happened so
long ago like just all this
like people say forgiveness how do you
do that oprah had oprah.com
and i thought how cool would be to have
your name
dot com
now
i sought this kid out so i went to
brendan.com and this guy he had his
resume up there
and that's all he had was a resume so i
emailed the guy and i'm like hey man i
really love to own this website
um could i buy it from me he goes no
it's my name like dang it
and he says uh no you know i got my mom
she's got you know
an email we have an email associated
with the domain right all this stuff i
said oh man
all right
every so i said in my calendar every six
months for six years whoa
my calendar would go off and i'd email
him again
email him again email him again email it
took six
years and my sixth year he said you know
what yeah you know
i'd be interested in that conversation
sold it so i got brandon.com i'm really
happy about that really thrilled that
stupid story but i was like yes
determination i found this quote um
that said you know the journey to
greatness
often begins the moment
that
challenge and contribution
become more important than comfort and
ease oh that's a good one yeah it's
really good and so we have to challenge
ourselves but the habit here the social
habit
is develop influence and you develop
influence teach me how to think role
model away and then make sure that you
are challenging people in those three
years challenge their character you got
to do that delicately the book teaches
you how make sure you challenge
relationships because that's so
important and challenge people what
they're giving and if you do that
strategically enough you know part of
your message in greatness is challenging
people
to follow their dreams you say it all
the time it's one reason i love your
show
you're constantly challenging people to
follow their dreams and not just like
hey follow your dreams like hey do this
i want to learn to be confident
i want to learn how to communicate well
and i want to learn to have great
relationships
so i studied those things really
intensely and i just tried them and i
tried them and i just i literally i was
so good about making little goal sheets
and trying and that was the year i also
began my monthly goals
so on the first of every month to this
day
i write a personal goal and a
professional goal every day i look out
on the way out i put on the door i'd
walk out and be patient no matter what
my other goals or objectives were that
was like the defining personal theme so
i created monthly challenge themes
for 23 years
you know patients have come up a lot of
times
it's like joy has come up a lot of times
yes you know uh uh staying centered has
come up a lot of times it's not like i
have ever achieved i've no one achieves
personal development i agree or purpose
it is like
an intention
and a dedication
and so that's where it started and by
studying all that
it gave me the edge
i really believe when you are a student
of life especially in psychology and
philosophy
you get the edge because when people are
having problems you can see perspective
around it
and once you have perspective you got
super powers
because most people are trapped in their
problems i'm extremely grateful for
the
patience and love of my family in this
particular project it took me away more
than anything else
uh i'm actually really grateful that
i've gotten to know you better
and getting this to be the first like
in-depth conversation with it yeah it's
fun because i think that you're very
talented at holding a space
for people your team too about holding a
space for people just be like
this is me this is what i you know about
yeah um
and then i would also
you know i'm always grateful for the god
for the second chance i got
from the standing under the car like i
got it
like
knowing that each day you get up
and you it's not
you know self-help
psychobabble it's like
knowing that life is limited and you get
a second chance every morning of like
showing the world more of who you are
you know breathing
taking that walk with your love
just having that everyday kind of new
beginning
i feel that in my career i'm sharing
that with you now and by the time this
comes out you know i'll have a new show
out the brendan show
i've never done that before as a new
opportunity i'm grateful for the new
opportunities i think right now you and
i have the ability to share our messages
farther and wider than we've ever had
before i'm super grateful that we're
alive like right now at this time on the
planet when i think
our messages really need to be heard
when we're you know surrounded sometimes
by a culture society politics is so
negative
to have a platform to share something
good right now i'm so grateful for that
the number one issue with being
productive isn't that you people usually
don't know what to do with the day it's
that they look at it with dread and they
accept that feeling and they stop
they i don't wanna so they stop
even though
even though if they looked past the
immediate dreadful activity and looked
into the future about the benefits it
would give them
if they could reconnect with that they
could push through
it's that when we get in the short term
just automatic feelings automatic
emotions that come up those things when
they're not monitored consciously
and sometimes they're not overridden
by a higher calling a higher ambition a
higher ambition to serve a higher
mission
then what ends up happening is we go ah
i'll do it tomorrow
i'll skip this one and you know i'll get
the workout in tomorrow and then
workout comes tomorrow i'll get it in
next friday and then it doesn't come in
next friday and then
i'll get the work in the work doesn't
happen we keep telling ourselves these
stories i'll do it when i feel like it
but i hope if one thing you've learned
here is the power plant doesn't have
energy it
you need to generate the energy in which
you need to excel and serve in this
world number
one is my friend hat which is so
important uh this is where when i'm
having a bad day i always say okay
if i was coaching my absolute dearest
best friend in the world who just went
through the same day
what would i suggest that they do
next
not how would i change their life not
some big high flu and stuff like what
would i suggest that person they do like
literally next
in that situation they're in would it be
you know what you really need to call
your mom you know what you you need to
call that person apologize you know what
you need to send that email you know
what you need to do is take this but
what would i tell my absolute
best most adored friend
to do as their very next step not the
whole plan just what's one thing i would
tell my absolute best dearest friend
i asked myself this question probably
two three times a week
right because i'll get frustrated by
something something will piss me off or
i'll be bummed that something crashed
and burned i'll be like okay would i if
my best friend just went through that
exact same thing what would i say they
should do
first and of course once i think of what
they should do first then the next step
comes and the next step and the next
step meaning
kind of coach and advise yourself from a
third party standpoint i know you
probably know you should do that but
here's the way that i make it stick
i write
the letter
this means i sit down with a blank piece
of paper and i write the letter to
myself from the best friend's
perspective dear brendan you're really
ugly and stupid but you're my best
friend so buddy here's what i recommend
you do
about the situation that you're in
here's how i think you should think
about it here's what i recommend that
you should do
and i literally write the letter
to myself
from the perspective of my best friend
does that make sense that's what i call
putting on my friend hat and i write the
letter dear brendan
and sometimes it's just i write it it's
super short it's on a little note card i
write like ten sentences other times man
i gotta dig deep and that thing becomes
like a four-page letter to myself you
know and we know
from psychology is specifically dealing
with therapy and trauma
that if you will write yourself a letter
it does significantly change your
emotional well-being
and writing it from this perspective
as a friend has i have found made my
letters much more compassionate much
more thoughtful much more positive so i
just put my friend head on i write
myself a little letter dude if you're
angry all the time you gotta change how
you look at the world
yes there's a lot in the news that can
piss you off yes there's a lot going on
that causes outrage all day long on
twitter or social media somewhere but if
that's your sole focus no wonder you're
upset all the time lots of people are
angry right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new
there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know are as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world
i mean the odds that you're even alive
and having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up you know one of my late
mentors was wayne dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground and he said
thank you
thank you
thank you
he was grateful for his day and he began
that way and i think so many people
right now they kind of roll up in bed
and they're like
and they grab their freaking phone and
they start going through the news on
social media and what are they cueing
immediately i'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
click make look at me click clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your a-game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be
solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem problem
problem outrage hour outrage but listen
when you become a solution based person
when you say okay i actually want to do
something about this problem and you
start taking positive steps to at least
address it or to participate suddenly
that anger goes into a new fire and that
fire is called enthusiasm
it is easy to switch anger into
enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay i
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation
turns anger often into enthusiasm people
say brendan i'm scared to start my dream
i'm like you're not scared to start your
dream you're embarrassed to be seen
starting small
big difference it's not about the dream
that's freaking you out it's about how
you're going to feel
chasing the dream it's about how you're
going to be perceived chasing the dream
it's about how you fear at night it
won't turn out the way you wanted it's
not about the dream it's about how
you're processing how will feel
chasing
the dream and once you figure that out
you see that you can rewire yourself you
can teach yourself to think differently
about the journey and the process
because look you know no matter how
small you start
start something that matters
start something that brings your life
back you know start something that makes
your heart feel full start something
that does scare you allow that fear
allow that worry allow that anxiety a
little bit because that's just saying
you're growing you're learning you're
changing you're getting going but let's
be very clear most people what they're
really scared about is being embarrassed
well i don't know if i quit my job and i
start this thing what do my co-workers
think when i do that i don't know if i
start this what are my friends going to
say when they see me playing small and
not doing big things because every big
project starts with small little tasks
that don't look sexy oh what's what's
everyone think about me that i chose
this route when the other thing was over
here and that was a better choice what
people are scared about is being
rejected or more being embarrassed
i tell people all the time don't be
embarrassed to start small i i think
about when i started doing videos you
know it wasn't we're 200 million video
views now we i mean tell you what when i
started i was okay with the fact that it
was like 10 people watched my videos you
know nine of them was my mom on
different browsers probably hitting
refresh to make me feel better about
myself you know like i accepted the fact
that starting small was part of the game
instead of bemoaning that i honored that
process i said that is part of it being
small in a big pond with big fish is
part of the game and only until you keep
playing keep moving keep building do you
ever become one of the big fish
you have to be okay with being small and
so if you start your channel or you
start your thing and only a hundred
people watch it hey that's a hundred
people
who heard your message that's a hundred
people who you help that's a hundred
people who you change your mindset for
that's a hundred people who let you do
your own thing and watch and even if
they were haters at least you started
penetrating their mind get in the game
never be embarrassed about starting
small or scrappy or crappy because
that's part of the journey it's supposed
to be that way so don't fear it
acknowledge that's part of it i'm gonna
honor that let's go i was a
maybe 24 or 25 year old man and i was a
member of kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or lions club it's a it's a
a
it's a non-profit organization that's
dedicated towards service in in the
community and i was in kiwanis and i was
the youngest one hands down like in in
the room we get together every single
month on a tuesday and we'd have lunch
and we'd have a speaker in and then we'd
talk about a volunteer project we were
going to do that month and that was kind
of how it went in kiwanis for me and so
but in my room
i was 24 25 in the room every tuesday
when we got together
everyone else was older i mean they were
like
50s and 60s and 70s older when i was 20
i was the youngest person in the room
every single time
and
i remember i was having a particularly
challenging time because i was thinking
about quitting my job but i was scared
because i didn't i hadn't saved any
money
um
i
didn't know exactly what i wanted to do
i just knew that i i knew that the job
wasn't the thing at the time
but i didn't know what it was and so i
was scared to make the leap and i was
just i was kind of struggling with some
existential stuff because you know i had
been four or five years i hadn't had a
girlfriend
and it was just frustrating i was like
dating but i wasn't able i just wasn't
making real connections on when i was
dating and i was just unhappy in that
part of my life i didn't know what i was
doing with my career i didn't have a
significant relationship i was like oh
man
i'm just kind of i didn't feel good
and so i was having a really down day
on that particular tuesday and i went in
and i was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the just one of the
awesome cowanians that who was there and
he was um i think he was probably 59 60
years old he was in banking
um very successful wealthy guy
happy hap just he was like a
happy-go-lucky grandpa type you know
just a good dude and i'm just kind of
listing off to him all these things that
suck
you know and he says what are you doing
about it and i said well you know i
you know and he says well i bet and he
said i bet i know what's going on he's
you're going home you're probably
watching too much tv drinking too much
beer and
sitting alone too often or you're going
out and not having any fun and
we're just talking my mode was yeah i
kind of i go inside so i kind of pull
away from people when i'm unhappy and so
i was like yeah i kind of pull away and
i'm in my house and he says why i know
how to solve your problem i said oh what
is it he goes buy tickets
like buy ticket when you even buy
tickets he goes i want you to open up
the paper remember the papers says i
want you to open up the paper and he
goes i want you to see what's going on
in your town
and i want you to buy tickets to
whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends
is it is there a symphony coming to town
buy tickets is there a ballet buy
tickets is there a uh an art museum buy
tickets is there he said is there a
concert buy tickets
and i said what do you mean i just buy
tickets i want you to buy one two three
four tickets and i want you to take your
friends and i just want you to go i want
you to buy tickets and i want you to go
and i'm like what the hell does this
have to do with anything i'm even
talking about he goes just buy the
tickets and come back next month tell me
about the tickets and i'm like no and he
literally pulls out his wallet and i'll
never forget he sets down three one
hundred dollar bills
and he goes
buy the tickets here's the money and i'm
like what are you even i was literally
so frustrated it's a long story short
i'll try to keep it shorter but so i
bought tickets i got a symphony ticket i
uh got a there was like a dance troupe
in town or something weird there's a
dave matthews concert
and what else there's one other thing i
can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets i
went with one or two or three friends
and
went to them and the second i remember
even i remember
the opening act for the dave matthews
band started and i was like
got it
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so
i was down and out and he got me out and
about and then with you with your
friends and you're socializing and it's
in a new environment and things are
happening and my mind just started
turning on again i started getting all
these ideas and these dreams that i
don't know where they were they weren't
in my room they weren't in my bed these
ideas and dreams they weren't happening
in my journal the the the ideas and
dreams they weren't happening in my my
daily planner it was like i was stuck
there
so he moved me over here have you ever
been like at a ballet or a symphony in
orchestra and you're just sitting there
and all of a sudden
you feel amazing
like the music hits you this idea comes
in and you walk out and you feel amazing
have you ever gone to a broadway show
you went in and you were frustrated and
freaked out because all the horrible new
york traffic and all of a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now no problem is
gonna slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to the seminar buy tickets
to the event buy tickets to the art
museum the ballet buy tickets and i mean
if you're down and out and your life
sucks right now go buy tickets for the
next four weeks and i promise you'll be
like damn
buy tickets that changed my life
changed my life too and i've learned
ever since then like if i'm down and out
it's like buy tickets
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there